now finally the man of the hour we're
here with Milwaukee Bucks Superstar
Giannis after the kumpo the honest man
has been a lot has happened over the off
season but but before we talk about that
how was your off season you do anything
special
um no not really
um I had the procedure on my knee yeah
took time to recover uh get healthy get
stronger
spend a lot of time with my family was
the first off season in a while that I
could be with my family because I wasn't
able to participate in the national team
yeah in the World Cup
that's pretty much it then I came back
and then now I'm ready you know getting
ready for the season you know I got
sources everywhere so I I knew I knew
about you in that barber shop and one
other thing I ain't talking about
everything that you were they were very
entertained with you with that barber
shop and what one of the things that
they won my people that was there told
me he was like yeah we asked him a
question we asked him like what's the
one player if you can play with anybody
what's the one player you would like to
play with and they said you mentioned
Damian Lillard at the time and now look
what look where we're at right now were
you speaking that into existence yeah
but
no I'm very excited to play with him and
top 75 won NBA
man uh All-Star the guy got ahead of
that killing Chris Middleton back there
messing around the Galaxy that's a
killer you know that plays the game you
know in a high level plays with the chip
on the shoulder like you always want to
play with guys like that no he's being
like
you know dominating this league and
running
this league for a lot of years now and
you know I'm happy that he's on our team
now and he's going to help us
you know uh be great and win the
championship guys you had a golden quote
that's making rounds already that you
said the press conference you said um
um paraphrasing but you said
it's good to make some money
[Laughter]
what's coming
no you did huh no it's not that I know
the question was coming first of all
right we talk about his potential
extension by the way but go ahead
the money is that important yeah oh yeah
I want to ask you before you get out
here y'all I want to ask you
how come
you don't
work out with other guys you see other
players working out with other guys
they're clicking up to you know it's
always like a big
buddy thing you've strayed away from
that it's kind of like the old school
mentality why have you taken on your
career like that so I think it's a very
long answer uh one go ahead we got time
I I I I I cannot fake it hmm
I I cannot I cannot fake it and um
how can we work out together you know
when we are
we are in the same we're in the same
league and we we're going against one
another
you know I'm trying to I'm trying to
create something for my family you try
to create something for your family
you know you you know I'm saying like
I'm trying to the reason I'm not winning
the championship it's you yeah the
reason I'm working out every single day
to win a championship and you you get
the you get on that you know in my path
in my way you know hiking how the hell
will I you know work out with with you
but at the end of the day as I said like
I I wear I wear my heart on my sleeve I
wear my emotions on my sleeve you know I
don't know how to be
fake I I mean I cannot do this and I
feel like the moment I you know I I work
out with players and then you have to
you know kind of maybe hang out with
them later then when you play them you
know you you you have to talk before the
game with them and then after the game
you have to sit down and have another
conversation with him and then when you
go to the family room you see them again
you gotta talk to them and then when you
see them in the post you want to put
your shoulder into their chest we cannot
do it because they might take some of
the game come on what you're doing like
I can't play the game like that
I do not work out with people that play
Maybe right now
that's what I you know so that is the
two different things if you if you if
you're not in the NBA I have no problem
working out with you you know if you're
in the NBA and I'm gonna see you in the
season yeah and as as I said like when I
get to get to the city I have to text
you to hang out to come to dinner yeah
and after dinner I don't know what might
be and then the next day I have to see
you before the pregame and then I have
to see you after the game and then we
have to oh that's a lot yeah I'm not I
don't need to do that with my my wife I
don't even take my wife today I'm not
gonna take you on a date what no oh
that's a lot yeah especially if you do
that every other night yeah no hey you
got me motivated and pumped up to kill
this season and my professor right there
so thank you for that little pep talk
right there hey that's the honest
Milwaukee Bucks two-time MVP appreciate
you brother thank you thank you